[Music]
the title of Grand Master was first
officially awarded in 1950 now in 2017
at the st. Louis Invitational that
tradition continues hello chess fans and
welcome back to st. Louis for the final
day recap for the 2017 st. Louis
Invitational we have had two players one
in the GM section and one in the I M
section that have earned norms and both
players have won their respective
tournaments near the end of today's
final round the top section looked like
there would be a five-way playoff
unprecedented here at the st. Louis
chess club but International Master John
Michael Burke put a stop to that when he
finished off Aman Hamilton and yes he
had the black pieces and that means he
wins outright we're here with the winner
of the GM norm section I'm talking with
international master John Burke who
today clinched his second Grand Master
norm and the tournament victory with a
black win against Amon Hamilton John you
said it was going to be difficult and it
definitely wasn't easy with the black
pieces against him on were you aware
though that with a draw you would be
involved in a five-way tie for first and
a playoff in that manner I was kind of
aware of what was going on with that but
I was too focused on winning because
even though winning the tournament it
was great I was a lot more focused on
getting the norm it's true a playoff
would not do would not earn you the norm
let's take a look at the game and see
exactly how you clinched the tournament
I was kind of lucky that I took a look
at the line he played this morning
because like five years ago I think
against two Mena's he played you for and
I was able to notice the move e5 and
that was played in that game too and I
think it completely kills the line in
fact Black is already a tiny bit better
and I was very helpful for me because
it's not easy to create anything with
black
your opponent wants to drop and yeah
already it's a bit more pleasant for me
nothing you know too amazing but I was
very happy to get this far already and
he has to be a bit careful here like if
he plays a move like this then I can
invade rook t2 and I think I'm already
doing very well one of the lines that I
looked at was like Queen III the idea is
that if I take on the c2 he can take on
d8 and then he v I have F 4 and if
Queenie 4
I have this nice move and I think I'm
winning here because if he takes on f 5
then I win the rook on d1 but he played
a better move and now he's threatening
to to play Bishop c2 because then I
don't have Rick d2 so I thought it was a
good idea to trade and try and leave him
with not a bad Bishop but kind of a
pinned in a tie down one and this was a
critical moment if he wanted to make
things very interesting he could have
taken the pawn because if I take on d3
then he has queen bee 8 at the end and I
had a couple ideas of what to do one
idea was this line but I wasn't too
happy with it because he can take both
my pawns and I doubt that I have
anything here maybe I'm a tiny bit
better but probably not a lot
another thing that I could do is play b5
and then he has a lot of places to move
his queen and the lines are pretty
complicated and I couldn't really figure
it out honestly I was pretty tired but
yeah I was very happy to see Queen e2
because then I knew I would get into an
endgame that if not winning was at least
very very closest yeah f4 is an
important move because he plays f3 k f2
at the right moment I'll have f4 and
that would pretty much when I think yeah
here he surprised me by playing with FV
one I thought he would play Rick Dida
you won because now if I play as I did
in the game then he's a full tempo up
and he he gets his king to c3 and it's
very easy draw but he was afraid that
I'd play like this but I don't think I
really have a whole lot here because if
I for example trying to invade with my
king then he can play rook e5 and take
my f5 pot so I was kind of relieved that
he played brick fe1 because now I got
the rook ending and I'm a tempo up on
the line that he could have played a
free play to eat you won because now if
he allows my king to come in
I thought this probably would be winning
for me because he can take on a five but
he can't take anything after that and I
can play King a two and if he comes here
oh I think I'm more than far enough
ahead because I can kick his Bishop away
and then play king c2 although looking
at it now it might not be that clear but
no I probably is because Davis
I probably play a faff but yeah this
isn't clear either but I think that I
would have been winning there with
precise play I don't really know how but
I think before was the the right try for
him and now it looks completely waiting
for me because I'm just gonna bring my
king to b4 and take on a c4 but he has
the nice idea and he found the only move
because if for example he plays like
king D - King before then now I can play
here and then it was very easy for me
because I'll take both his opponents and
he can't play here because they take and
take and it's a completely winning
opponent in but yeah he has this move
because now if I play King before then
he can come here and is already probably
a draw because if I defend my pawn he
can defend his or if I take on a c4 and
take like for example
this is like the game but there aren't
the pair of pawns left on the board and
that would make this a very easy draw
for him I think because I can't really
bring my King in because his King will
always be able to come in and attack my
pawn like if I play King high five
he can even play this because if I take
then his King will take my pawn and then
run over and I'm not winning there so I
thought that the only try would be to
take the pawn immediately and then try
and run my King in and yeah from here
from this point on I mean we looked at
the game afterward I think we figured
out that it was probably winning for
black but it was very complicated and
I'm not 100% positive right now but I
think that he could have maybe started
with Bishop f3 to force me to move my
pawn because in later lines I wanted my
pawn back on b7 and yeah I think he
wants to keep on a long diagonal anyway
so I was kind of happy to see what he
did here and now my plan is just to
transfer my Bishop to the the long
diagonal and he can't get his there
anymore
yeah and he might have an idea of
playing like a g4 g5 to restrict my
pawns so I thought that I have to play
here and now for example if he has if he
plays this then I can play here and he
can't take because at the pond ending is
hopeless and otherwise he loses his pawn
well technically he can play Bishop d1
but yeah this is why I want my pawn here
and yeah now the whole idea is that I'm
gonna try and get my King in but he'll
be able to cut me off
whether it's like if I get just c1 he
cuts me off and now let me go to d1 or
he doesn't let me get to be one to begin
with but either way I have ideas to try
and force him away yeah now he has to
give ground because you can't play King
D too campy to and I'll just come in or
yeah here's no other movie
and now at at this point I got kind of
worried because I realized that he has a
bishop t5 and I completely missed that
for whatever reason if he changed to my
if he trades then it looks like he has
enough to keep me out but I can run all
the way over and that he has to give
ground but yeah I think this was a
better try because we'll get what we got
in the game but a full tempo up for him
and that might be enough to draw because
I have to come here to defend both my
pawns but now he has time to bring his
King over and he can cut me off here too
and I can't get in and we were looking
at ideas of bringing that came back and
trying to win from there but it was very
very difficult like for example if he
plays waiting moves then I can't do
anything over here and my only other
idea would be to try and bring one of my
pieces back around but if I like bring
my bishop around then he can come after
my pawns and I might even lose there so
I don't know it's very complicated
didn't have to be very careful and if
there is a win then it was very
difficult but luckily he didn't realize
that we would get that later in the game
but a tempo up for me he thought he
could avoid that but now now I think I'm
winning because he doesn't have enough
squares on the diagonal now the idea is
that if he goes here
then I can trade and completely winning
this is a better try but I went anyway
because I can cut him off like that and
then again he has to give ground because
if he goes bishop f1 then I go King d1
or King d3 King b2 and I bring my King
back and I went to c4 pawn he had to go
after my pawn but now I'm luckily a
tempo up on the line from before because
now he doesn't have the two moves to
bring his bishop to the long diagonal
like he did in the other line and so now
I'm completely winning the only trick is
that I have to be a bit careful if I
take the pawn immediately and I think
this is still winning because but even
though I'm I can just cut off I can play
here now and I'm threatening to bring
making not hang out anything f3 I can
come behind and if he lets me play
Bishop d3 to e4 then out get making out
and if he takes the pawn then this is
completely winning because I'm gonna run
my two pawns to distract him and if he
goes after them then I can get making
out and run my other pawn but I didn't
even have to do that because I can play
here and he has nothing to do but wait
and now I can defend my pawn and now he
has to play another waiting move but
then I can even just bring my Bishop out
and and I want to play Bishop before and
if Bishop d5 I think I can just come
behind now because I'm threatening to
take his pawn and there's not a lot he
can do about it maybe he can go here
anyway and that would transpose
I know if you take some f5 then I can
bring my came out and if kf2
then I can defend it so yeah I didn't
even need the line from before where I
go after his c4 pot but even though that
would be what he - it was not the time
that I wanted to calculate because they
had load time as well so yeah I think
this critical error was not taking the
opportunity to activate his bishop
earlier with with Bishop d5 not here but
wherever it was
yeah here and yeah I don't know it might
just be a draw maybe I have a computer
like win but if there's one then I
couldn't find it so I was very relieved
that he didn't play that yeah well at
the end you guys were both really low on
time now there's a 30 second increment
does that do anything to relieve the
pressure of that end game a little bit
because then it's the type of end game
where I can if I want to just make a
couple of random moves you know I'll be
fine so if I really like had to gain
time in that matter than I could have
but yeah even with the increment I was a
bit worried Ben Feingold always repeat
well you have two norms now is the third
one immediately in your crosshairs no I
don't even know the next norm corn
around playing I'm just gonna go back
home and relax who knows it might be
here anything else you'd like to add as
we congratulate you on your victory
not really I'm kind of tired to be
honest yeah well we still have a big
dinner and you know Thanksgivings coming
up congratulations John Burke on his
second GM norm let's take a look at the
final standings for the top section here
at the invitational five and a half
points that saw all of these players
tied for second place so they each take
home $1,000 which is the combined prizes
of second through fifth place divided by
four international master John Michael
Burke has two Grand Master norms to his
name
and he is the winner of the GM norm
section of the Invitational he takes
home $2,000 the IM norm section wasn't
as easily decided as justin weighing and
international master torres both drew
their games bringing them to six and a
half which meant that the two players
would engage in a playoff blitz style
alright welcome to the 2017 st. Louis
Invitational playoffs we have a tie in
the I am northern section with
international bastard Torrez and
national master Justin Wayne he actually
got this first international master norm
so congratulations Justin and now we
will play the playoffs but before the
playoffs we will do a drawing of the
laps they will play two games game in
five minutes with a three second
increment
congratulations to Justin when he won
the International Master of dorm 1 the
section as well and a check for $1,200
so give it up for an EXO master just the
way it took two games in the playoffs
but we have the clear-cut winner right
here the winner of the International
Master norm field is the one and only
Justin Wang Justin congratulations on
your victory today I know that you
thought that you might have to end up
playing I am Torres in a playoff and
that's indeed what happened first
thoughts here you just got done with
these games moments ago went to straight
to an O to win this playoff how do you
feel right now I feel pretty happy but
let's see how it happened take us
through the game I know in the first
game it was a blitz game five minutes
with a three second increment and you
had the black pieces take us through and
show us what happened okay so one first
critical moment here was 93 my position
was had some holes in it but I think I
could but he hasn't isolated upon so I
could take advantage of that Queen I
think Queen da just queen da is just
safe and I could keep an advantage well
fortunately I played beef woods and he
played Bishop e5 and that now if 28th it
weakens the g-force Quinta he can maybe
they should do Bishop e6 so after 94
Queen h5 f3
rook c6 look I played this was bad but I
played it because I wanted to play f6
and I couldn't couldn't have played it
one move earlier because he can do
something like this
and then I lose even more material so
now I've Division II foot my position is
bad and [ __ ] Queen B 5 is also possible
put planning to play Queen d7 but [ __ ]
a d5 is also okay after here
Bishop F Bishop f6 is a bad move
yeah because I just play Bishop FA and
he has no Knight flick I think H 3 here
just better is just better
my queen cannot really move anywhere and
my book doesn't do anything so all of my
piece is not in a position or a stock if
I play Bishop c4 here he could look c1
yeah he does this if I do hear me votes
my queen not here after king h1 Bishop
c4 Queen e1 loses if Queen c2 I can play
Bishop basics but Roxy 1 is the saving
move the knife to bf eat a look at C a
king
h7 Knight takes then here the only way
to stop me is d5 well okay Jay taking my
queen is fine so after Queen e1 here is
already lost in in the next game the
first critical moment was when he played
rook F CA me maybe just Bishop d3
probably better move or just look g1 but
played Bishop c4 and now he sacrificed
his rook after night b2
he played with d8 which was bad he
probably didn't see my queen t8 no I
think I think his best move is just
queen x evil
so after Queen da I I just gotta I got a
good position but I kind of lost it and
then at the end he gave up his night for
nothing
and that was it he resigned
International Master Torres Luiz Torres
goes down and has to settle for second
place after that playoff Justin you're
not a bad blitz player do you enjoy
Blitzen
your free time yeah kind of I play
online with a with an increment like
that that was bonus for you maybe I
would what's better off without
increment do you have any big upcoming
tournaments you plan on participating in
I'm gonna play some tournament in my
state right after this tournament but
it's not it's in a chess club so maybe
not very big you're 12 years old
when we talked to players who are that
young who are coming up in the chess
world as quickly as you are the question
is where do you see yourself in your
chest future how far do you think you'll
go no no depends how hard I work and
hopefully I can become world champion or
something
that's it remaining top 10 that's a
tremendous expectation to have for
yourself and I commend you for that
Justin congratulations one more time it
was great talking to you the winner
you're welcome in your welcome great
guest here Justin way one of the guys to
keep your eyes on in the chess world and
he is the winner of the International
master norm event tied for third place
in the I am norm section Matthew Larson
Erin Griffin ski and vitality namer
these players each take home $600
it took a playoff to stop international
master from Mexico Luis Torres he takes
home $1,000 for his efforts in this
event and the phenomenal Justin weighing
it takes home this entire
tournament after clinching a norm one
round early 12 year-old Justin says
someday he'd like to be the world
champion he takes home $1,200 for this
performance in the invitational thank
you for joining us here on YouTube chess
24 and u.s. chess champs calm for the
coverage of the 2017 st. Louis
Invitational congratulations once again
to Justin Wang an international master
John Berg until next time this has been
Simon saying so long from the
show-me-state